S
NOW IN JERUSALEM.
THANKS SO MUCH.
DOZENS OF FAMILIES IN KABUL,
AFGHANISTAN, SPENDING THE LAST
DAYS OF RAMADAN BURYING THEIR
DAUGHTERS AFTER A GRUESOME
ATTACK OUTSIDE A SCHOOL ON
SATURDAY.
WE'VE JUST GOT AN UPDATE THAT
THE DEATH TOLL HAS RISEN TO 85
KILLED.
MOST OF THEM YOUNG GIRLS.
AND ALMOST 150 OTHERS WOUNDED.
THE TALIBAN SAY THAT THEY ARE
NOT RESPONSIBLE.
AND HAVE ANNOUNCED A 3-DAY
CEASE-FIRE FOR THE EAT HOLIDAY.
FOR THE FAMILIES IN MOURNING,
THERE'S NOT MUCH TO CELEBRATE.
>> WE LOVED ONES GATHERED TO
BURY THE DEAD.
DOZENS OF SCHOOL GIRLS KILLED
IN A BLAST AS THEY WERE LEAVING
CLASS ON SATURDAY AFTERNOON IN
KABUL.
AND ON CALL CRIES OUT.
>> SHE WAS 15 YEARS OLD.
STUDYING IN CLASS 8.
SHE WAS VERY INTELLIGENT AND
DIDN'T MESS UNTIL DAY OF
SCHOOL.
YESTERDAY HER MOTHER TOLD HER
NOT TO GO TO SCHOOL BUT SHE
SAID NO I WILL GO TODAY.
BUT I WILL NOT GO TOMORROW.
SHE TOLD THE TRUTH.
AND WE BURIED HER HERE TODAY.
>> AFGHANS INTERIOR MINISTRY
SAYS A CAR BOMB INITIALLY
EXPLODED FOLLOWED BY 2 IEDS
JUST OUTSIDE THE SCHOOL.
FIRST IT WAS THE CAR BOMB.
THEN THE 2ND BLAST WENT OFF.
AFTERWARDS CAME TO 3RD.
I DID NOT PANIC.
I RUSHED TO THE SCENE AND
SUDDENLY I FOUND MYSELF AMONGST
BODIES.
WHOSE HANDS ARE HEADS WERE CUT
OFF AND BOATS WERE SMASHED.
ALL OF THEM WERE GIRLS.
I SAW DEAD BODIES PILED ON TOP
OF EACH OTHER.
>> THE AFGHAN GOVERNMENT BLAMED
THE TALIBAN, BUT THE TALIBAN
DENIES ANY INVOLVEMENT, BLAMING
INSTEAD THE ACTIONS ON SINISTER
CIRCLES OPERATING IN THE NAME
OF ISIS.
NO GROUP THOUGH HAS CLAIMED
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE ATTACK.
MANY INSURGENTS IN THE COUNTRY
ARE KNOWN TO DESPISED EDUCATION
OF GIRLS.
BUT FOR THE LOVED ONES, NO
CLAIM OF RESPONSIBILITY WILL
BRING BACK THE DAD.
>> LET'S TALK MORE ABOUT THIS
WITH FATIMA GONI, SHE'S A
WOMEN'S RIGHTS ACTIVIST.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
AFGHAN --
SOCIETY, AND ONE OF 4 WOMEN
INVOLVED WITH THE ALABAMA PEACE
TALKS.
SHE JOINS ME NOW FROM DOHA.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR DOING SO.
DO YOU WORRY THAT THIS HORRIBLE
ATTACK IS A POINTER IN MANY
WAYS TO WHAT COULD BE TO COME
IN TERMS OF THE ADVANCEMENTS OF
RIGHTS AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
AFGHAN GIRLS AND WITHIN IT IS
CLEARLY A MESSAGE?
THE OTHER DAY WHEN THIS
HAPPENED YOU GUARDS WITH THE
ENTRANCE EXAM FOR THE STUDENTS
TO GO TO UNIVERSITY, I THOUGHT
WHAT COULD BE WORSE.
BUT THEN CAME THIS.
THIS IS THE WORST THING THAT WE
COULD'VE THOUGHT OF, MEN OR
WOMEN HERE, BUT THIS IS
HAPPENING WITH THE AMERICAN
SOLDIERS ARE STILL HERE AND
NATO IS STILL HERE.
WAR IS STILL GOING ON IN
AFGHANISTAN.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO'S FIGHTING
ANYMORE.
THE TALIBAN SAYS IT'S NOT US.
THEN WHO WAS IT?
THE GOVERNMENT AND THE TALIBAN
AND EVERYONE, IT HAS BECOME A
BULLY GAME OF BLAMING EACH
OTHER.
THIS IS THE WAR.
THIS IS THE 43 YEARS OF WAR
WHICH HAS GIVEN THE STUFF
PEOPLE, DOING THINGS LIKE, THAT
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO THEY
ARE.
ISN'T AT THE TIME FOR PEACE?
ISN'T IT THAT THE WORLD COULD
HELP US?
>> YOU WOULD HOPE.
SO THE THING IS YOU HAVE A
UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE.
YOU LIVED THE BEFORE AND AFTER
THE TALIBAN REPRESENTED
AFGHANISTAN AND TOOK
AFGHANISTAN.
YOU LITERALLY --
WHO BANISHED WOMEN LIKE YOU
FROM PUBLIC LIFE.
IT MUST FEEL INTENSELY PERSONAL
TO CONTEMPLATE A POTENTIAL
RETURN TO THOSE OLD AND
TERRIBLE DAYS.
>> WE HAVE NO INTENTION TO TURN
TO THOSE DAYS.
THE WORLD SHOULD NOT ALLOW
SOMETHING TO HAPPEN, AND THE
PEOPLE OF AFGHANISTAN, ABOVE
ALL, SHOULD NOT LET THIS
HAPPEN.
WOMEN OF THE PIANO STAN ARE NOT
THE WOMEN OF YESTERDAY.
THERE ARE MILLIONS OF DEDICATED,
EDUCATED, VERY, VERY STRONG
WOMEN IN AFGHANISTAN, WHO WILL
NEVER ALLOW SUCH A THING TO
HAPPEN.
THAT'S WHY YESTERDAY WE HAD A
PROGRAM WITH WOMEN.
AND THEY WERE SAYING ONE THING.
HE HAS TO COME.
THEY WERE ASKING FOR ALL OF US
TO START HERE AND START THE
NEGOTIATIONS AGAIN.
BUT FOR US IT'S NOT JUST A LACK
OF WAR.
PEACE MEANS INCLUSION.
PEACE MEANS THAT MEN AND WOMEN
OF AFGHANISTAN ARE INCLUDED IN
EVERYTHING IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAW YESTERDAY
THIS SHOULDN'T HAPPEN ANYWHERE
IN THE WORLD.
>> OF COURSE NOT.
>> WHO WILL WE BLAME?
NOW WHERE WE WANT TO BLAME?
>> YOU SAY THAT THE WORLD
SHOULD NOT ALLOW A RETURN TO
THOSE BAD OLD DAYS.
DO YOU TRUST THE TALIBAN?
THOSE WHO SAID THAT WOMEN'S
RIGHTS WILL BE PROTECTED.
THERE ARE DIFFERENT FACTIONS OF
COURSE WITHIN THE TALIBAN.
THERE ARE PLENTY ON RECORD TO
SAY THAT THERE WILL BE A RETURN
TO SHARIA LAW.
A RETURN TO WOMEN BEING
SIDELINED AND REPRESSED.
WHEN YOU SAY THAT THE WORLD
SHOULDN'T LET IT HAPPEN TO YOU
THINK THAT THE WORLD COULDN'T
DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT IF THEY
LET THE TALIBAN TAKE OVER?
>> LOOK.
THIS CONSTITUTION TODAY WE HAVE
IN AFGHANISTAN IS NOT A SECRET
CONSTITUTION.
IT'S A ISLAMIC CONSTITUTION.
EVERYTHING FOR WOMEN IN THIS
CONSTITUTION, I AND MANY WOMEN,
MEN AND WOMEN WHO HAVE STUDIED
ISLAMIC JURISPRUDENCE CAN
DEFEND IT.
WE CAN DEFEND OURSELVES.
IT'S THE WAR WE CAN'T CONTROL.
IF I SAY THAT WE WANT THE WORLD
TO HELP US, I WANT THE WORLD TO
HELP US TO END THE WAR.
AND WHEN I WAS IN A
CONSTITUTION, WHEN WE WERE
WRITING THIS VERY CONSTITUTION
REGARDING WOMEN WE DID HAVE
OTHER PEOPLE ON OUR SIDE WHO
WERE IN THE SAME IMAGINATION,
AND IN THE SAME WAY OF THINKING
LIKE OUR TALIBAN'S ARE.
BUT NEGOTIATIONS AND TALKING,
AND BREAKING SCHOLARS WHO COULD
EXPLAIN THINGS HELPED US.
NEGOTIATION WILL HELP US.
BUT WILL NEGOTIATIONS START?
LOOK, WE'RE SITTING HERE FOR
WEEKS, AND WE WANT TO START
THAT.
AND I URGE THE TALIBAN, I URGE
THE WORLD TO HELP US TO START
NEGOTIATIONS SOON AFTER EID.
BECAUSE AFGHANISTAN CANNOT LIVE
LIKE THIS.
WE CANNOT LIVE THE WAY THAT WE
SAW, AND SCENES LIKE THIS,
AGAIN, AND AGAIN, YOU CAN'T
BLAME ANYONE BECAUSE NO ONE
WILL TAKE THE RESPONSIBILITY.
>> EXACTLY.
IF THIS WASN'T THE TALIBAN, IF
IT WAS ISIS, WHICH WAS ENTIRELY
POSSIBLE, WHEN IT COMES TO
THESE SORTS OF ATTACKS, THIS IS
A MESSAGE, IT'S A MESSAGE AT A
GIRLS SCHOOL.
WHAT CAN THE WEST DUE TO
PRESERVE THE GAINS THAT HAD
BEEN MADE THAT YOU THOUGHT TO
FOUGHT TO MAKE?
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE THAT THE
ANSWER IS ANYTHING BUT NOTHING,
IN A REAL SENSE, IF THE TALIBAN
WOULD COME IN AND TURN THE
CLOCK BACK, WALK IN THE WEST
DO.
IS THERE ANY REASON THAT WE
SHOULD BELIEVE THAT TALIBAN
WOULD ABIDE BY WHAT THE WEST
ASKED TO DO.
>> THE CLOCK WILL NOT TURN
BACK.
THIS IS A NEW AFGHANISTAN.
THE TALIBAN WILL HAVE TO TALK
TO US.
WE WILL HAVE TO COME TO A
CONCLUSION ABOUT WHAT KIND OF A
AFGHANISTAN WE WANT, ALL OF US
TOGETHER.
IT CAN'T BE THAT AFGHANISTAN.
AT THE TIME IT TOOK OVER, AFTER
A CHAOTIC SITUATION OF CIVIL
WAR BETWEEN THE G.O.A.T. AND
THE --
EVERYTHING WAS SO BAD THAT THE
TALIBAN LOOKED GOOD, AND THEY
CONTINUED.
TODAY IT'S NOT LIKE THAT.
WE HAVE A CONSTITUTION.
WE HAVE A COUNTRY.
WE HAVE A GOVERNMENT.
YES THERE'S CORRUPTION AND
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT
ARE BAD.
BUT IT'S NOTHING TO COMPARE
WITH WHAT IT WAS BEFORE.
THIS IS A GOVERNMENT THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
IT'S THE SYSTEMS THAT WE HAVE
TODAY.
ALL WE HAVE TO HAVE IS FIX THE
SYSTEM TOGETHER WITH THE
TALIBAN, THE WAR HAS TO END,
WHEN THE WAR ENDS WILL KNOW
WHO'S DOING WHAT.
YOU SAID WHAT THE WEST CAN DO?
>> AFGHANISTAN STILL NEEDS
HELP.
AFGHANISTAN WILL HAVE TO GET
HELP FROM ALL THE NATO
COUNTRIES.
STRINGS HAVE TO BE ATTACHED TO
THAT WHICH IS WOMEN'S RIGHTS,
HUMAN RIGHTS, INCLUSION AND THE
RIGHTS OF MEN MINORITIES.
I DON'T WANT TO DIFFERENTIATE
BETWEEN THE RIGHTS OF WOMEN AND
OTHER MINORITIES.
WE HAVE TO LIVE TOGETHER IN
HARMONY.
I'M FROM THE GENERATION BEFORE
THE WARS.
I REMEMBER HOW AFGHANISTAN WAS.
I REMEMBER HOW WE LIVED
TOGETHER.
ONLY WANT TO GO TO THAT.
DON'T WE DESERVE THAT?
>> YOU DO.
I WAS AND IN JANUARY AFTER THE
TALIBAN WAS KICKED OUT, AND I
SAW THE RELIEF AND THE HOPE IN
THE PROMISE THAT PEOPLE WANTED
FROM THAT.
YOU'VE DONE EXTRAORDINARY WORK,
WE HAVE TO LEAVE IT THERE, KEEP